what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch Chucky season two
episode five today I hear it's a good one John how
are you I'm very excited sir how are you I'm doing
good I'm excited for this ladies and gentlemen
leave a like that would be very much appreciated
also special thank you to all super sexy rejects
those are the ones who follow us over our patreon
page showing their support really do appreciate
it full interaction watch along is where you sync
up with your own copy of Chucky available over
there along with a bunch of other shows that we
cover exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included your support means the
world ladies and Gentlemen let's see what's
going on in this highly talked about episode
this one is flexi just picture it jutting out of
her heart if that little [__] had a heart don't
you ever say her name Lexi's not your mouth Jagged
blade is gonna make him scream like a little girl
[Laughter] these are for you
and your good buddy Jake friends
oh he's getting defensive wow
round one fight Chuck how did you get to be such
a wuss I found something better than killing don't
[Music]
how did this Chucky murder so many people you're
not good Chucky I am good check [Laughter] you're
supposed to be a killer like me yeah oh wow oh
no buff Chucky stop it there's nothing you can
do okay just that I can take each other out let
them take each other out gotta save good Chucky
Chucky ah Devin just thinks of Chucky's a
Chucky still you're weak pathetic you're
nothing you're the Chucky no one will remember
that's not true the word of the Lord [Laughter]
awesome [Laughter] I'm the Chucky I choose to be
[__] yes Iron Giant Chucky wow he's crucifying
him oh my God oh my God Colonel Chucky died for
our sins of how he got the idea to crucify him
oh yeah off camera vomit Killing In The Name
holding up two Chuckies interact with each
other like that going toe-to-toe for you coach
how can you just see past even though it's
good Chucky I'd have the hardest time scene
past the fact that it's a Chucky doll yeah
never trust it he's a killing machine he saved
Our Lives he saved us from Chucky he is Chucky
we are Chucky but you still have me I'm not gonna
let tricky take you too there is no good Chucky
huh don't say don't confuse him
don't have this conversation in
front of that Chucky only good Chuck
he's a dead Chucky that was awkward
I would love it if good Chucky is
manipulating this whole thing the
ultimate disguise I would never
put it past them great of course
I find this act of blasphemy
deeply disturbing look at the blood
God damn it
there's a corpse in the closet and a killer
doll on the loose I'm worried about me
I'm 18. ouch I had five gerbils and my mom would
tell me that they ran away I couldn't figure it
out why would they leave me you can open the
door Lexi I don't think she ever wanted me to
have any of them at all but you know how moms
are they do their best to make you happy right
my mom she's really good at
being sweet when she wants to be
[Music] sharing her drug addiction they're
gonna kill her off this season aren't they
or she might become a killer [Applause]
[Music] then just a poop drops in there too
nicely done you're gonna regret it
I already regret it for you Lexi
the seed
to remember
you don't want to put that in a text message
you murder people Glenn it's an addiction have a
little compassion [Laughter] start with who Nika
is and what happened Mika's my girlfriend and
sometimes your fathers stop lying who's
Tiffany Valentine I'm not saying anything
until you tell me where Glenda took Nika all
of a sudden you have nothing to say Chuck made
Chuck mate please yes thank
you sir may I have another
what maybe it's a miracle praise
be the God what did it feel like
when he killed him like I
finally knew what I was for
holy hematoma Batman the Joker got me good and
the citizens of God uh oh Trevor's gone as I know
in the place we left him we don't know how many
Chuckies are out there what if one found Devin
no he's he's fine he's just being dramatic and
punishing me don't lie to yourself Jake dramatic
and who would take Trevor's
body though an ally or an enemy
uh
uh you would know how could I possibly convince
a believer of Supernatural evil it must just be
a series of violent elaborate pranks pulled off by
some traumatized teenagers open Leviticus and read
it read a little bit of Leviticus you can believe
in a man being resurrected from the dead after
three days but you can't can't believe about a
supernatural doll the Bible's full of Supernatural
evil weren't you the one that recommended these
violent kids be admitted here in the first place
and where have you been during the reign of terror
throughout these hallways this this sick abandon
of everything holy what what God is trying to tell
them what I am trying to help them see therapist
is totally in on this in some way and is currently
reading the Bible in the chapel by himself and
that's where he will remain until father rice
is that really necessary maybe these kids need
someone to talk to I mean are you punishing him
for blasphemy or for Creative prowess why not both
foreign this is a display of violence and
Casual pageantry Devin is a traumatized kid
this is evil evil well I did not become a
sister to validate or answer to your fits
of self-righteousness this is not an Inquisition
this is exactly what it is best none ever nobody
expects the sour Inquisition I think I can
still help him get rid of that Abomination yes
no one notices the blood nope
looking right past it [Music]
buff Chucky lives
nice
read the shellfish one next
oh no dude
oh my God he's gonna torch the chapel
oh boy you remember that time in high school When
We snuck out to meet with the Dean
Brothers what what were their names
you're smart it was a little
long ago it was almost like
we were different people I want
to be Jennifer Tilly yep [Music]
no way do you have a check for me God wait is that
would that be Jennifer Tilly inside the precious
I'm starving you promised me chocolate
no way she's still alive that's hilarious
so beautiful that's me I look
beautiful anyhow that's awesome
laughs the ever-expanding lore
or could I possibly give you
guy
I need to convince your sister Meg that I'm you
Meg is here tell me about those Dean Brothers
yep oh Jennifer plot plot away I just feel
so bad who would do something like that
are you kidding me you would do something
like that you're basically responsible for
killing Jake's whole family for some
reason he doesn't seem to care about
any of that because I wasn't his fault that was
a different Chucky he's not like that anymore
oh my God he looks so upset I
I have to go no you can't no no child actors
no come back adorable kid did I really do those
things no that was a different you there's a lot
of you but you know you're all different kind of
easy yeah really if I came from from that means
that I'm bad too that means I could hurt you no no
you choose your own identity I know you're
good what if there's still evil inside me too
wow like I have an idea we're gonna need
some help I really like good Chucky I do too
fascinating moral quandary even when we thought
Chucky was dead Jake I mean none of us ever saw
each other ever and I wanted to talk to you
guys every single day everything just felt
it's hard you guys are a reminder
what's that is that a doll's foot
what so you've been Captain Chucky's
breadcrumbs what you know like Hansel and Gretel
like he's leaving a trail for
himself to find his way back home
gotta follow it so then the priest usually
says something like what do you ask of God's
church for Chucky I ask for a clean slate
cool you could have also just said baptism
you could be my godfather Jake
oh yeah sure do you want to be The Godfather
ew [Laughter] [Music]
I baptize you in the name of the father
keeps me crazy that's a wild
[Music] and the Holy Spirit [Music]
cleansing you from your original sin
that's it you're you're clean now
no more evil wow what a feeling and it
was so easy you are very suggestible
[Music]
I don't know what the hell's going on
awkward why not the new Cult of Chucky is
formed oh what are the therapist is from
The Cult of Chucky like between the
asylum as a worker it's a good guess
no no leave sister Ruth alone you will believe
[Music]
oh my God that's not gonna work
call someone in I am risen oh
you are risen indeed Lord and it
didn't even take me three days
how can I serve thee Lord oh God that's
so ridiculous there's a new cult in town
Cult of buff Chucky when you
were talking about the Dean
Brothers earlier it really
brought back some memories
they wanted to raise money for or even if
they grew up and so they got the whole band
back together and then the cops were acting in
for their unpaid parking tickets but they still
managed to play The Palace Hotel down the hutch
they still managed to save the orphanage yes but
that is the plot of The Blues Brothers that's very
familiar yeah [__] excuse me I have to go okay
Jennifer it's a great plot beat you tricked me you
little troll huh I don't know what you're talking
about disgusting little sweaty pants aren't you
I'm going to make you sorry you ever were born
oh no I used to be the most unhappy dolly in the
world Mom oh no oh no it's not what it looks like
Jennifer Meg it's me Jennifer in here I'm in
here now what looks like what is going on here
oh my God Meg is so dead yeah oh my God
yep no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no [Music] ugh
did she die like this in
Psycho too is that what this is
so ridiculous
rest in peace it will be missed what
have you done you've done he was my sis
Destiny Valentine and I'm your goddamn mother
is coming to her own damn this is
Jennifer Tilly's season it's about
time it's really doll is Jennifer
Tilly she gets to play Jennifer
such a mind Bender
kill you mommy's here you
Maniac you [Laughter] I am trying to have
an important conversation with my child if
you don't shut up I won't lock you down here to
start do you understand me no more shut up foreign
never good at being Jennifer Tilly and
I wasn't that good of a mom either you
don't say look at you yeah and he
did the same thing to you kids also
[Music] I have one last birthday present
for you no [__] you got the doll yeah
I thought they transfer they
transformed not a transference [Music]
I thought it was like Jen gave birth
to twins yes no It's gotta be the doll
we just gotta get Billy Boyd back
wow full circles man it's me
kinda it's for them too I
need to show this to them
let's go get them okay alone I
need to show this to them alone
[Music]
no no no no
so kill Jennifer Tilly
they did take Jennifer Tilly
how good oh my God we are
Seed of Chucky and that's full
seed full seed ahead [Music]
it's really a trail uh or just a
spot for a bunch of dead Chucky whoa
is Andy like living out here tribal
style every dead Chucky's win right
but why was that Chucky taking
photos of stuff if it was Andy
maybe lead the trail to him
there's your boy
holy [__] Andy what how'd you recognize Auntie
yeah seriously I didn't even recognize it from
that Sean looks more like Jesus the therapist is
in on it yes [Music] Charlie that's carnal to you
[Laughter] thank you wow wow
what a cool episode that Falls it's not the same
ball Chucky from the first step the first episode
of the season I think it is it's the same exact
one he didn't have that voice he's just doing
another brand new impression right Apocalypse Now
yes absolutely it's a brand new impression I mean
it might be a different ball Chucky or maybe just
bald Chucky has slowly devolved into Marlon Brando
oh that's funny Chuck of Darkness all right
take it away John now this is a blast good to
be back among the uh you know the main cast and
whatnot back at the school but uh I liked the
the blending of things out of the last episode
we certainly got back to the main plot line but
everything with Jennifer Tilly and just the
I know people get conflicted about seed of
Chucky's camp and it's you know kooky metatone
and and the comedy the overt comedy that takes
hold when you're in that world's aesthetic but
uh I I love the way that they continuously just
Kaleidoscope the lore outward and yeah now you
have you know direct confirmation like okay
keep it Jennifer until he's all trapped here and
that makes a lot of sense as to how she's able
to live this life and so it's like it serves a
practical uh a practical uh purpose but also you
know adds to this the crazy weird ever warping
blend of characters these people get to play uh
you know because there's been so much made out
of like uh Fiona duraf getting to do just like
every possible iteration and now it seems like
Jennifer Tilly is also getting that opportunity
come full circle and it was so cool to hear
her it's like you really realize how much of
a character she puts on be like because she's
playing Jennifer Tilly you know it's heightened
or she's posing as Jennifer Tilly and and you're
in this show you know it's heightened but like
hearing Jennifer Tilly's voice protesting back
really reminded me just how much of a character
Tiffany is at all times and so uh yeah I love
that detail having Meg be the one it makes perfect
sense like it's a fun gag but it also serves
another practical uh purpose where yeah she's
the one who's like something's off here you don't
seem like the Jen I know and I love that they use
that to their advantage you get a fun kooky
death with her uh and then yeah cutting back
over to everything else here you know you've got
Jake slowly falling into the Trap of good Chucky
which I'm really curious to see how it plays out
I mean I think probably everyone's a little sus
at the moment uh for good reason but uh yeah
I I really enjoyed the blend that this episode
episode made because the stuff with the school is
appropriately foreboding and a bit more serious
in tone and then the stuff at the Tilly house is
uh you know tense certainly but you know zany as
well so uh yeah I really enjoyed especially on
the heels of such a deep dive into a particular
idea and meta concept last week I really like this
as a return to the overall big picture and uh in
confirmation that nobody dies if you don't see it
happen for Andy so uh yeah what do you think sir
uh yeah I think that this was uh to me this is
probably my favorite episode of the Season thus
far I think that it has the perfect world building
of everything I really enjoy about this Chucky
franchise and it's pretty awesome to see just how
because what the Chucky franchise it really seemed
like there was a certain set of films and then you
had the camp era of the films then I was like we
got to go back and take it a little more serious
and be very horror-centric and something that just
feels more serious basically something scary again
and then to have this show where it just has this
great Collision of events where it doesn't feel
at odds with with the franchise it feels like
it actually honors the franchise in its totality
because they're doing everything that I love about
the franchise even the crazy campsite but they're
even converting some of that camp stuff and making
it more serious like when you compare I think the
death of red man or uh Jennifer Tilly at least the
presumed death and the circumstances of the the
interaction with real life celebrities in their in
that movie seat of Chucky it that just registers
as totally goofy you know it's like super silly he
didn't cry when Britney died no no that wasn't the
real Britney Spears that was an actress pretending
to be Britney Spears so when when basically with
that film it is very it's very goofy and then my
point with that is while like the last episode we
had like Joe pantaliano like them dying is Goofy
they had mag Tilly here and until I pulled myself
out of the you know moment to be like this is just
kind of crazy because they got Jennifer Tilly's
sister to appear here and now they're killing off
Jennifer Tilly's sister yeah yeah and it's not
like the way you would feel in seat of Chucky
it's not like the way you would feel in even
a movie like this is the end you're taking the
moment serious like it's a real character death
and and it has repercussions of a reveal for
um Glenn in the room to be witnessing this and for
the Revelation that my sister is in this this doll
and trying to process all this information and
what it's doing to Tiffany and her coming into
her own because so much of her character portrayal
of what Jennifer Tilly was doing suddenly made a
lot of sense it already made sense but it made
even more sense because it was revelatory about
her character where she does have that line of I
am Tiffany Valentine and I am your goddamn mother
like the way she Embraces that and then the the
speech where she's lamenting her whole feelings
of why she wanted to be Jennifer Tilly and how she
really felt like she's just a total deadbeat she's
I think she said I'm a loser really she feels like
I'm a loser when she's talking with uh with Glenn
and then you're seeing like oh yeah she's been
going like this whole depression and losing
herself and alcoholism and then one can chalk it
up too she's just she's Tiffany Valentine that's
just who she is she's just kind of a crazy girl
you know but it's not bad like there is a whole
deeper character side to it so there was something
that felt very much like coming into her own and
an Embrace about Tiffany Valentine this episode
so as much as we're getting like crazy cool Chucky
stuff you know like with good Chucky because
it could be a ploy it could be a manipulation
but hell the lengths are going through to if it is
good on them because I've definitely jumped on the
the train that is telling me that this Chucky
is having a real existential crisis because
they do want to be good I believe it you know
like running off wanting to be on their own
defending you know the the defending Jake and
Devin by trying to keep like attempting to kill
um buff Chucky like there's there's so much
about that good Chucky that just seems like
that this truck he actually wants to be good and
fears the evil and fears like the labeling in the
pre-existing conditioning of where the roots of
Chucky are like it's a fascinating existential
thing to do with the character and also the the
sometimes I feel like obviously there's some
choices that could be more logical like any horror
thing is it especially in the Chucky franchise
but I appreciate what they do on a deeper
character moments of how they make it very nuanced
with the relationship Dynamics because I I enjoy
what they're doing with how you got a Good Guy
Chucky and you got two different responses from
the the lovers from Devin and how he's reacting to
it and and Jake who's like they're both empathetic
but their traumatic responses and their reasoning
is reacting to this doll quite differently you
know and then it brought me back to the beginning
of season one where Jake did have a buddy he did
have a friend and it was that Chucky doll when he
was a loner you know and so to finally have that
Good Guy Chucky doll makes sense to me why there
might be a part of him that you know when you
when you have sometimes when you grow up in an
abuse you have this certain empathetic quality
that makes you want to see the good in some one
that might be bad something it can make you do
the complete opposite it can make you totally
resistant but it could also develop this other
quality and and uh and and I feel like that's why
he really roots for a Good Guy Chucky to remain
Good Guy Chucky so I think they're doing like all
these exciting things I don't know what this means
with the therapist it seems like the therapist is
in on it in some way she has to be she she has a
bell doll she has to be she's always been sus yeah
absolutely and I guess Colonel Chucky's the one
calling the shots but but I think yeah it's it's
funny and it's exciting and it's suspenseful
and they're they're meta nods I think are
I think they're I like the handling of the meta
nods like this more than I did the last episode
you know because they they build
it into the universe so well of
like that Family Guy reference I think is kind
of brilliant yeah yeah because it because it
absolutely Works in Universe yeah yeah you could
do this all remotely you don't necessarily like if
Tiffany needs to go to take a meeting or something
as you can but yeah Jen could just record all the
stuff at home I think that's brilliant and keep
the fortune some like it answers so many logical
questions and yeah it makes a real legit I think
that's the thing is like people don't love certain
people don't love the bride and Seed era of Chucky
because it is you know a bit all caution to the
wind and I feel like here they've tempered it
really well so that it Honors that Spirit but
it's also conscientious enough to spiral out of
like an interlude like last week's episode and
then yeah use what we brought in clearly not just
for fun and games but for yeah actual progression
of the story actual expansion upon the lore and
I liked what you brought up with Jake because I
feel like that would be a lot of it would be I
think difficult for certain viewers to swallow
but yeah you have that relationship that Evan
never had you know or Devin I should say Devin
never had uh he only knows Chucky you know in
the most horrific way possible whereas yeah you
have that Slow Burn of the first season's start
to where Chucky and Jake are bonding and that's
you know an evolution to figuring out like okay
this is a really bad situation and so I think
it's also a nice way to add yeah some dramatic
tension for our characters this it makes sense
um and and yeah you know and and plays on
something that you can kind of chart back into
the history of the show to show that okay this
isn't just a way of going ah what's a new thing
we can do it is but it's also really motivated
and I think that's that's what continues to
impress me about the season is no matter what wild
choice they make it seems like they've also really
thought it all through and that allows I think the
traversing of tones so you can have stuff that's
wildly outrageous and funny and then you can have
stuff that is actually like scary and tense and
that does make you wonder and yeah I'm with you
I'm like I hope good Chucky is good because I
think that making that be a real thing as much as
it would work for it to be a ploy making that real
does feel like a new and interesting thing to
do with Chucky that we haven't seen done before
and part of this franchise and especially part
of the show is anybody who gets to be a Chucky
kind of gets to now twist through every possible
version that that could imply and I like that
yeah they've done that with Fiona duraf they've
done that with Jennifer Tilly and now even here
they're doing it with Chucky himself and that
gives you know Brad duriff a chance to change
up his voicings which has happened in the past
but I think is especially notable here uh as
he you know brings these different Chuckies to
life and whatnot and and yeah like I I love the
addition of that I can't imagine good Chucky is
going to make it through the entire season the
whole like baptism thing like it's so wild and so
absurd and uh and yeah it's it it it plays on the
aspects of the Christianity angle to the season
that they've brought in in a way I never really
would have thought of or expected and it you
know it asks very interesting questions and now
I wonder you know what will happen in the rest of
the season as you have Tiffany embracing herself
coming into her own letting go of her Jennifer
Tilly Obsession to a degree uh and you know going
back to to her self her own motivations and then
you know these iterations of Chucky most of which
are you know the one she definitely knows but you
know you've got this one and I wonder if they will
ever cross paths and what that could bring to the
table moving forward so yeah like I I love both
the focus but also the sort of wild possibility
and I think they've really managed to like you
said acknowledge the series in its totality and
to not even like I know Don Mancini doesn't like
as much the voodoo angle of things but even that
like everything that's come before seems to be
incorporated in a way that's conscientious and
it doesn't feel ashamed or displeased with any
particular element it has to work with it just
knows how to properly embrace them in a way that
doesn't fully undermine the fact that this is
still you know horror and stuff but also you
know really Embraces that fun and uh and just a
wild Spirit are in the DNA of this franchise yeah
yeah I think with the church thing it
started to really click for me the angle
of what they're doing within the church because
I've been wanting to really get a good grasp of
why why the church setting what they can do other
than the most obvious thing to predict would be
the uh you know homosexuality is it Abomination
yeah because of Jake and Devin's relationship
so that again uh but this episode really put the
perspective uh into a much more clear light of
no it's the cult it's the cult mentality that this
this season is dealing obviously Mancini has an
interest in cult and has an angel fascination with
cult and this really like the example to me like
the baptism was a case of brainwashing where
it's like a literal form of brainwashing all
over again it's washing like if we do this this
will convince this person that they are good and
then you have the nun who sees for some reason
projects who Christ must be unto buff Chucky
and then decides I will obey just because the
song rise out of a trash just because it's a
miracle of some kind yeah it's it's very and then
also the you're seeing with Devin sawa's uh priest
character the stringent self-righteous ways he
goes about um reacting and responding to things
like the only one that doesn't feel like a cultish
like character is the I don't know yeah yeah she's
she's she's great and feels very relatable and
of course I got Alexi and Nadine and I like I
like what they're doing with them having like a
genuine friendship you know that's something we
didn't really get I don't remember of Lexi having
just a real friend and them being able to be there
for each other and I appreciate the discussions
even though Lexi and Devin have of you know yeah
they were bonded by trauma but when sometimes when
you're trying to move on that trauma just seeing
that person could be a reminder even on a very
subconscious level that just brings you back in
an emotional mental way so to for them to interact
not be interacting makes sense because they're all
trying to move on in whichever way that might
be whether that be drug addiction or I'm trying
to form a relationship with my my new brother
whatever it might be but then of course it's the
the Catalyst of another dramatic inciting incident
that unites them it's like they're bonded by
trauma and I think there's a lot of I think
there's a lot I I guess that's the bottom line
of what I kind of get at with I don't really say
it's about the movies I mean some of them there's
deeper [__] for sure I will definitely give it
that that's there's often sometimes there can be
a deeper commentary or something more interesting
to explore a theme yeah I think this show um does
something very impressive for me where they keep
the entire Spirit of the movies that preceded
it very much alive but do something much more
nuanced as they move forward without it feeling
like you're talking to me you're actually still
doing a real story and you're keeping the energy
involved so yeah I think it's very I think it's
really well done and I thought this episode was
one of their best so yeah alrighty guys well what
did you think about Chucky season two episode five
we're not able to watch these and it was at the
very end of the video most of you guys will not
get this message we're not able to just get access
to it um properly until like Thursday so I started
coming out on Fridays so sorry I'll just hit up
3C films and see what he does he's the Chucky he's
the Chucky midnight Pacific Standard Time don't
get how he does it it's very impressive he sneaks
into sci-fi headquarters the shows that people are
like wow you got this out so fast I'm like yeah
I can't figure it out for Chucky it's the one one
show I'm having the hardest time with it um leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click that Bell
leave a like and let's send this with a patreon
Andrew Hayes Andrew it's Thanksgiving
month so I wanted to give thanks to you for